[Applause]
as coronavirus rampaged around the world
britain could see what was coming but
was still unprepared
a year on the failures in hospitals and
care homes are familiar
but even in that deadly spring the uk
was placing its bets
in a great vaccine gamble that today
is paying off the vaccine effort has
galvanized
science business regulators and the nhs
behind the single goal
of saving lives but its success began
with a small group of experts thinking
not like public health officials
but like investors deciding which of
more than 100 candidate vaccines
to back with hundreds of millions of
pounds of public money
they placed their bets on seven
committing to buy hundreds of millions
of doses
before they knew if they worked
remarkably six do
five have completed clinical trials
three are licensed for use and two
have already been administered to 15
million people
steve bates was part of the team are you
surprised at how many of those bets have
come in
i'm amazed i genuinely thought that
there was a decent chance that we'd be
talking at this stage about why we'd
spend
lots and lots of money on things that
didn't stand unearthly of making any
difference whatsoever
we were betting on this before we knew
whether the clinical outcomes were
strong
in some senses that's a nonsensical
approach
[Music]
the team moved fast striking early deals
for the homegrown oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
and with pfizer beyond tech the first
jab to prove its effectiveness
and the uk the first country to
administer it
every step of the way there's been a
collaboration
that has um been defined by
speed agility and rapid decision making
so no lengthy bureaucratic processes
in any organization on our part on the
government
on nhs or the regulator and it's been
unprecedented
what if we now apply that to cancer what
if we apply that to alzheimer's
when small u.s biotech firm novovax
delivered hugely promising results
the uk vaccine team were quick to offer
funding and support
would you consider you know working with
us in uk
that would be manufacturing use our
clinical trial network which
i knew was very good before the call and
maybe we'll fund you know fund this
activity so
so the answer was yes yes yes and that's
been a fantastic collaboration
it's been really enabling to work with
the uk
and uh they they like our technology so
um i think this has been a grand success
distribution has been a triumph of local
nhs
networks gps nurses and volunteers like
here
at cheltenham fire station they're ahead
of national targets and are learning all
the time
they dose patients standing up where
possible to save disinfecting chairs
and the teams compete to be the most
efficient every day
we do 120 patients an hour of six pods
and we're working 12 hours a day so as
long as the vaccine supply is there
we can vaccinate 7000 a week it is the
most humbling experience
any of us have ever had because we're
making such a difference to people's
lives
the vaccine team is already looking
ahead signing a deal with german company
cureback targeting new variants
the uk will long weigh its coveted
failures
what went right with vaccinations may
offer more positive lessons
for the future paul kelso sky news